Good to see you, kid.
What can I do for you?
Going back to school
made me realize
it's the wrong place for me right now.
Hey. I need to be out there.
You need to start calling on me again.
You think I haven't been watching early
morning outings?
That's why I need you.
Hold on.
I'm better and stronger. I'm ready.
No, you're not.
You're not. Mark. What?
What do you mean? I need to do more.
It's only been a month. More.
I can save lives.
Welcome back, everyone.
It's Charlie.
This will be my Invincible
Season 2 Episode 1 Opening Scene Video.
They dropped one of the opening scenes
from the episode.
There's a bunch of Easter Eggs here,
So explain what's going on and I'll be doing
weekly episode videos
when it does start in a couple of days.
if you're brand new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe to get all those.
It is going to be awesome.
It is probably one of the best superheroes
there is next to the boys,
I would argue that it's actually better
than a lot of Marvel stuff that's been
coming out recently to,
they're even doing a live action invincible movie.
But Robert Kirkman
didn't say when that's actually going to happen.
I'm assuming it's going to be
at least a couple of years like Jeffrey Dean
Morgan seemed like he was teasing a big invincible
role, but I think that's going to be
for the animated series in a future season,
like for season 3,
really hoping he winds up
playing a version of Thragg or maybe Conquest.
He could do either.
Like he would be amazing
as any of those characters.
end, even though J.K.
Simmons is amazing as omni-man on the show,
Jeffrey Dean Morgan would also make
a badass version of live action.
Omni-Man.
but the whole idea in this clip here, as you could
probably tell, is the specter of on demand
looms large like this is all about the aftermath
of what happens after he left the planet.
a little bit of time has gone by.
Not that much in is basically Marc
trying to get Cecil to let him start going out on
officially sanctioned missions again because
he wants to work with the Global Defense Agency.
Cecil confirming that They've also been
watching him since the events of season one,
when Omni-Man outed his true
mission to the entire world and went on a rampage.
And everybody is just kind of been worried about
what might happen next Cecil basically tells them
that he's still traumatized by his father's
betrayal, learning the full truth about his guilt.
You might heritage like it was all a big info
dump.
A lot happened in that finale for Mark
basically he was created
with the purpose of taking over the world.
And that's the whole reason why he exists
and Cecil is basically trying to tell him
to like back up a second
and just take some time to process that.
end, even though it seems like Cecil doesn't
trust him because of Omni-Man as revelation,
you would expect him to not trust Mark everyone,
including the Guardians of the Globe,
All the active heroes right now serving the Global
Defense Agency, are very wary of him.
But it's not clear like they're
trying to get across during this scene here
that Cecil is kind of on Mark's side.
He's kind of rooting for him to be true when he
says he's not going to turn out like his father.
he's hopeful.
But Cecil is not a fool that's
why he'd been developing all those contingency
plans for Omni-Man just in case things went off
the rails with him since he came to the planet.
there, all those scenes during season one
where they were trying to see
if they could affect Victor.
My cells like are there anything that we can do
in essentially the closest he got to a deterrent
to vulture mites were the Rianna men, which
they had upgraded again at the end of the season.
Like they gotten a little bit better
through the course of the season.
Like, okay, we have ones that are pretty tough.
But he still fought them off during the finale
until they upgraded them
even more in that Post-Credits scene.
they're couple other heroes out there
that are super powerful,
but none of them are nearly as powerful as Mark.
With a few exceptions,
like Battle Beast is still more powerful than him
So right now there aren't a lot of things
the Global Defense Agency has that could affect
Mark if he went off the rails, too,
which is why everyone's so wary.
they basically been watching him like a hawk
since the events of season one.
The knightly adventures that he references
are invincible going out each night
since Omni-Man loved trying to save people
take down random villains, proving to himself
and the rest of the world that he's still a hero.
He wants to atone for some of what happened.
getting into the weeds a little bit with power
scaling in the invincible universe,
like just talking about planet Earth right now
in the story when things pick up.
battle beast is more powerful than him.
He's not quite as strong as Omni-Man was,
but he's still stronger than everyone else
the reason why he's not quite as strong is on
demand is for a couple of different reasons.
Like technically he's only half the ultra my and
going with the whole Superman Kryptonian parity
that the bill termites are supposed to serve
as Normally you'd expect people who are 100%
will try to be even more powerful,
like a whole Superboy Superman analogy.
Like Superboy will never be quite
as powerful as Superman
because he's only half of Superman's DNA.
but one of the differences
between vulture termites and Kryptonian is that
they're meant to parody is that in the invincible
universe, the way they explain vulture
my DNA is that it's so strong, it
actually overpowers other DNA it gets mixed with.
So even though Mark is born
half human, half filter, might the build
from a portion of his DNA
essentially dominates his body so that he could
theoretically become
almost as strong as a full vulture might like.
It's not a weakness that he's half human
now within their race though,
there are people who are 100% build might
who have vastly different power levels
than each other because it's a little bit
like real life bodybuilders.
there's really no such thing
as like 100% power levels for Bill termites.
When you're Bill Termite, you could continue
to train your body and just get stronger
and stronger.
And because they're nigh immortal, they're aging.
Process continues to slow.
The older they get for example,
Omni-Man is almost 2000 years old
when he comes to planet Earth
before Mark is ever born So unless Bill termites
are killed in battle, they could theoretically
live for hundreds of thousands of years,
if not more, and just continue to train
and get stronger and stronger and stronger.
so the idea is that right now when the story picks
up, Mark has just hit maturity
like his powers have just kicked in.
the longer he lives, the stronger
he'll get an older man
is just had 2000 years to continue to train
and get stronger and stronger and stronger.
the same is true for all the other vile termites
like frag, for example, who's meant to be
the most powerful, vile right in the universe,
like way more powerful than omni-man
That's mostly because amongst adult termites,
Drag has trained his body the longest
and he was born stronger at the beginning,
like he started out stronger, bigger,
and then trained harder
for longer than most ultra termites.
kind of like Arnold
Schwarzenegger was born naturally, much bigger,
with much more potential for power
than a lot of other bodybuilders.
so theoretically, there's no limit to how powerful
bill termites mark, for example, Invincible
could potentially get when Cecil mentions
that Mark should take more time to process
trauma with his mother, they're still shaken by
what happened in his original desire
to go to college with Amber,
who's still going out with him
at the beginning of the season.
that stuff that he wanted to do before Omni-Man
revealed the truth to him in the Season
one finale.
Like he used to want to go to college
with his girlfriend.
Now not so much now he's completely obsessed
with proving to the world that he's still a hero.
some of the changes
the showrunner said that they made to
the original comic book storyline
was mostly to expand the story with extra material
for some of the supporting characters
because the episodes are hour
long instead of just being half hour long,
like traditional animated episodes.
the original comic book isn't that long,
so they just have way more extra room
to deal with storylines for other characters
that they did in the original comic book.
So Robert Kirkman has been working with them
to expand the story for these other characters.
one of the best examples of that is that Adam
Eve episode.
Expect them to do more of that in future years.
in the original comic book, when the events
of season two pick up, the story mostly
just follows Invincible as he's trying to clean up
the messes left over from the season one finale.
Like all the villains,
they tease at the end of season one that tags in.
You see some of them in the trailer,
And during the original comic book,
you didn't see too much of what happened
with the aftermath and his mother, Amber
or the others, like how they dealt
with everything that happened with Omni-Man.
Mostly they just plow right into the Engstrom
Libby's storyline.
he's the main villain,
at least for the first half of season two.
They're only releasing the first four episodes
and then the second for like the second
half of the season will be sometime
early next year.
but his storyline is going to be straight
out of the comics.
But like I said, expanded just a little bit
from what it was in the original comics.
They said they're going to spend
a little more time
in this first half of the season with his mother
in his personal relationships,
like the other characters, Adam Eve,
the new version of the Guardians of the Globe,
just explaining how they deal with things
after On Demand leaves the Planet.
it if it wasn't clear that Guardians of the Globe
team still exists,
they just cycled the roster season
just put it new members on the team
they kind of covered that during season one.
That's what all the tryouts were about.
At the time,
Omni-Man was still hiding his true plan,
but he forbid Invincible
from trying out for the team
because he secretly plan
to have them take over the planet.
the whole idea is that Omni-Man planned to set him
up as the new ruler of the planet per vulture.
MIT's new methods for conquering other worlds
Omni-Man would just leap, go to another planet
and do the exact same thing over and over again
until,
you know, theoretically, he died hundreds
and hundreds and thousands of years later.
That's how the village might essentially conquer
the rest of the universe
with a very small number of built
from its currently existing the whole difference
with the Angstrom Levy's storyline in the first
half of the season is that
he's like the first big villain that Mark faces
is sort of like a crucible for him,
kind of like a test for him to prove that he means
what he says when he says he wants to be a hero.
it's also the opportunity for him
to see what things were like
in an alternate universe because Angstrom live,
he gets into the whole multiverse of it all.
showing him another reality where Mark did side
with his father and helped take over the planet
Like this is what things would look like
had you actually agreed with your father
enjoying the other build termites.
so it's meant to catalyze Invincible
in his beliefs that he wants to protect Earth
and be its main hero.
like, if he doesn't do that,
this is what will happen.
Like, things will go really, really bad.
My. Full episode one video will post Friday.
I don't know if they're going to release
just the first episode or the first two episodes.
Whatever they wind up releasing.
I'll do a video for it.
They're supposed to release
most of them on a weekly basis, though.
My Loki
Season 2 Episode 5 Video will also post
on Friday and my boys Gen V finale video.
We'll probably have to post on Saturday.
I don't think I can actually do
like three big episode videos in a single day.
That's just like a little too much.
make sure you enable alerts for my channel
so you don't miss any of that.
And click here for my full invincible Season
2 trailer video and Easter Eggs
and click here for my Loki Season
2 Episode 5 Video.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!